and dozens of distinguished speakers are
once again joining efforts to find best
solution for the transition towards a
more sustainable economy we were here
today from the policy makers here in the
heart of the European Union but also
from the EU Partners from across the
Atlantic and from all over the world
two years ago on the initiative of the
European commission president Ursula Von
delay and the European Union increased
its climate ambition they used 27 member
states endorsed ambitious climate
targets for 2030 and the objective to
reach climate neutrality by 2050. the
European green deal is the use growth
strategy with dedicated investment plan
to unlock Investments and finance for
the green transition in the European
Union and Beyond however since February
2022 the situation in Europe has
worsened dramatically War has returned
to all continent
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is not only
bringing unbearable suffering to the
Ukrainian people it is also threatening
the security and the sovereignty of the
EU and is causing hardship around the
world with the most vulnerable countries
affected the worst
for the European Union it is clear that
it is its dependency on Russia's fossil
energy Supply must come to an end
with the repower EU plan the European
commission proposes to to make the
eu-wide Energy System more resilient by
phasing out fossil fuels from Russia
well before 2030. diversify energy
supplies and boosting Energy Efficiency
as well as investment in renewable
energies while ensuring that secure and
clean energy remains affordable to
companies businesses and the households
the second edition of the EU sustainable
investment Summit is an opportunity to
send a clear signal that in spite of
Russia's attempt to disrupt the
international order the world needs to
remain United in its fight against
climate change and we are inviting all
of you to join us here today during the
day please use the tool called slider
where you can ask your questions and
make your comments let us know what you
think about some of the most important
issues these days in the European Union
but also in the world we're going to
hear from the speakers we're going to
hear from the panelists and the sessions
and we're going to hear the keynote
addresses and the first one to open this
year's event is coming from the
president of the European commission or
Solomon Tulane
distinguished guests colleagues
activists
investors and leaders across the field
of sustainability
I am delighted to open this year's
sustainable investment Summit
since we met last year
global economic growth forecasts may
have weakened
but our Collective commitment to
building a sustainable economy has
certainly not in fact
the business
security
and moral case
for the green transition has only become
stronger
the same fateful week Russia invaded
Ukraine in February
the leading Authority on climate change
the ipcc
issued a stark warning to the global
community
they demonstrated that the climate is
changing faster than our capacity to
adapt
and the message could not be clearer we
must speed up sustainable Investments
and increase their scope
now more than ever despite Russia's
attack to disrupt the international
order
the world must remain United in our
fight for peaceful fear and prosperous
future
I would like to focus on two points
today that you will cover in more depth
in the panels
first on public investment
which is needed to mobilize private
capital
and second on empowering workers with
skills to drive the green transition
so let's start with public investment
our immediate priority is tackling the
energy crisis which risks becoming an
economic and social crisis
already at last year's Summit
I spoke about the unsustainability of
the energy system
which is still dominated by fossil fuels
now since Russia's brutal attack on
Ukraine this has become even more
obvious
Putin is using fossil fuels as a weapon
against Europe
but Europe will not be blackmailed we
will not compromise on our values we are
determined to end our dependence on
Russian fossil fuels once and for all
and fast
for example by diversifying Supply
saving energy and accelerating the
rollout of Renewables let me give you
two figures
last year 41 of Europe's gas Imports
came from Russia
now today this figure is down to nine
percent pipeline gas
we were able to compensate these losses
through increased Supply by our trusted
Partners like the US and Norway
in parallel
we have filled our gas storages to over
92 percent
and this is significantly higher than it
was last year
and we have managed to save 15 of the
gas consumption
but we have to go and steer the medium
and long-term transition at the same
time so we have proposed re-power EU
an investment support to cut our
dependence on Russian fossil fuels by
accelerating the deployment of
Renewables
renewable energy is not only good for
the climate
it is also good for our independence
it is clean energy produced at home
gas pipelines are being built fit for
purpose for green hydrogen
interconnectors are being completed to
create a europe-wide electricity grid
to support the mass deployment of wind
and solar
so we are investing in the
infrastructure
and Technology
needed for full transition to a low
carbon economy
repower EU will come as additional
Firepower and acceleration on top of the
recovery and resilience plans of the EU
member states
to date the commission has given the
green light to nearly 500 billion euros
from Next Generation EU
of which half support the green
transition
this includes measures in sustainable
mobility in Energy Efficiency
investments in Renewables and in grids
let me give you some examples
and France's plan
85 000 ecological bonuses have already
been distributed
to support the uptake of clean vehicles
and this is just the start
because much of our public investment
is designed to help de-risk and mobilize
private capital
like for example in Italy's plan
where Next Generation EU funds are being
used to boost their National Innovation
fund
this is to finance private Investments
that have a positive impact on research
and Innovation for low-carbon economy
the measure in Italy aims to support 250
small and medium-sized Enterprises with
700 million euros in sustainable
investment so
this is the right way to go
because we need entrepreneurs and
private investment to help get the job
done
and that's why we are here today
the green Innovation is here
the public investment is here and the
path is clear
this is a truly exciting moment for all
of us who believe in sustainable
progress
and this brings me to my second point
people
the so-called human capital
this is a Core theme of today's Summit
and for very good reason
they are entrepreneurs with big projects
and dreams
and companies with ambitious plans to
decarbonize
who simply cannot find the professionals
with the green and digital skills to
work with them
in Europe right now we have the
strongest labor market in decades but at
the same time
we have a serious shortage of the right
skills
this is a trend that has picked up
especially in the last two years
as we recovered from the pandemic
lockdowns
The munich-based ifo Institute has found
a growing shortage of skilled workers in
almost every EU member state
across economic sectors
from manufacturing to services
for example in construction which is a
pivotal sector for the clean energy
transition
nearly 35 percent of EU firms
report impairments due to shortage of
skilled workers
that is why I have proposed to make 2023
the European year of skills to focus our
attention and sustainable investment on
this crucial issue
at European level we've set Targets on
re and upskilling and made available
large amounts of EU funding
nearly 1.5 billion euros in Next
Generation used so far
and 4.2 billion from the European social
fund
but it is about more than funding it is
about bringing Industry and Training
providers together
employers associations with trade unions
the goal is to better match Skilling
strategies with the economy's need in
our labor market
and this is an approach we are
pioneering with a pact for skills
we have created 12 large-scale
Partnerships offering Skilling
opportunities
to 6 million EU citizens of working age
for example nearly 1 500 graduates and
workers have already received training
in the offshore renewable energy sector
this is great news because offshore wind
for example in the Baltic Sea and the
North Sea is a huge and clean power
source
both for Europe's energy independence
from Russia and to meet our climate
ambitions
because it is the people and their
know-how who drive positive change
ladies and gentlemen
if we take a step back
we have identified where investment is
needed
in clean energy
in Green Tech and skills
and the list goes on for we haven't even
spoken about biodiversity
the potential of green Innovation and
growth is immense
but to unlock this potential we need to
shift the entire Financial system
away from an unsustainable practices
towards Investments that are truly
future proof
the European Union has created the most
advanced sustainable Finance framework
globally
we're working hard to walk the talk on
sustainable investment for example we're
on track to be the world's largest
issuer of green months to finance
Europe's climate-related reforms and
Investments
so far we have issued 28 billion euros
in green bonds
continuously attracting significant
oversubscription for our issuances
this is a boost not only to Europe's
transition
but to the green bond market itself as
investors will have access to a very
Liquid Green curve over time
sustainability is much more than the
right thing to do
it is although the safest
and the smartest investment we can make
betting on a low-carbon economy
that gives Back To Nature more than it
takes
and reinforces our security
is the most certain economic Trend in
the coming years and decades
thank you for your leadership
thank you for your pledges
and I wish you an exciting Summit
and following the words of the European
commission president on the importance
for the EU to work with the trusted
Partners we're going to hear next from
the prime minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau
hello everyone
bonjouratos it's great to be joining you
for the EU sustainable investment Summit